buongiorno ragazzi bentornati a una
puntata di cucina buttata ora la
quarantena non mi sta aiutando
tantissimo nel reperire gli ingredienti
ma la cosa positiva è che esiste
internet e soprattutto esistono i vostri
commenti sotto il mio ultimo video ho
letto infatti un commento di una ragazza
diceva perché non provi a fare la torta
all'acqua all'acqua purtroppo mi sono
perso il commento di una ragazza perché
prima cosa che ho fatto appena vista la
detta questa cosa è stata a darci a casa
effettivamente esisteva una cosa simile
e dopo una lunga ricerca su internet
durata molto poco perché non ho pazienza
ho trovato questo riuscito a leggerlo
bene
manco io torta all'acqua su giallo
zafferano e esiste davvero potete
immaginare la mia gratitudine nei
confronti di questa ragazza del momento
in cui ho scoperto che questa torta uno
non sa uova 2 non al latte 3 a una
preparazione di 15 minuti e una cottura
di 50 facendo la matematica dice sì a
farne otto di fila nel tempo che ti ci
vorrebbe per vedere tutta quanta la
trilogia del signore degli anelli e
questo vuol dire tanto si potesse
giungere ancora di più ma non lo faccio
difficoltà molto facile dosi per 8
persone che questo periodo quindi sono
le dosi per una popolazione a costo
molto basso qui dicono provate a
immaginare una torta simile alla torta
senza uova ma non solo senza uova anche
senza burro credo anche senza torta
pensate che sia impossibile noi vi
diciamo no con la torta all'acqua
leggera e soffice e soprattutto più
consistente verrebbe da dire alla
portata di chi ancora alle prime armi in
cucina e non ha molta esperienza con i
dolci e non ha nemmeno voglia di vederne
uno la torta all'acqua e deliziosa da
leccarsi i baffi conquisterà tutti
provare per credere
beh ragazzi non vedo l'ora di berla
anch'io per fare la torta all'acqua
avremo bisogno di 300 grammi d'acqua 300
di farina acqua 200 di zucchero acqua
temi che polvere acqua olio di semi
acqua acqua acqua un baccello di
vaniglia vanillina quindi istigato e
acqua ma soprattutto tanta tanta poca
voglia di cucinare iniziamo subito qua
dicono
per prima cosa
setacciare 700 grammi di farina siccome
oggi non vive di presente utilizzare una
tecnica pazzesca tu metti una bilancia
sopra o sotto una ciotola e ben vero
l'inter mette gli ingredienti e difesa
non c'è tempo da perdere oggi ho una
vita una vita nella garantendo che devo
fare per un botto 700 grammi di farina
non c'è una luminosità a metà dell'opera
setaccia setaccia setaccia mi cuore
dimmi che vuoi setacciare anche tu un
300 grammi e un non so che cosa sia o
qualcosa alla fine quello che otterrete
è il set di narcos
andiamo avanti è passato anche il
lievito quindi formando un po l'esito
c'e niente setaccia mi tutto anche il
vito seta cielo sopra e mettete un
attimo a quanto dicono mi dicono
emettere un attimo parte fanno sprecare
altri e ciotole stronzo utilizzano un
piatto allora in un'altra tazza a questo
punto aggiungiamo si taccia ciao in un
altro big che aggiungiamo 200 g di burro
e zucchero ragazzi 200 grammi di
zuccheri ma vengo io a questo punto
aggiungiamo i 200 g di farina o 300
grammi d'acqua una cosa importante che
dicono del sito è mettere nell'acqua
tiepida in modo da permettere allo
zucchero di sciogliersi più facilmente
generando mescolando bene con la frusta
per far sciogliere lo zucchero non con
un cucchiaio infatti volevo usare una
frusta la frusta
oddio mi si è rotta ma con un coltello
incidete un baccello di vaniglia nel
senso di lunghezza e raccoglie dei
semini che andrete unire all'acqua e
allo zucchero ok io non ce li ho quindi
aggiungete la vanillina perché comunque
c'è una vita io ho novità alla quale
tengo moltissimo e un isolamento da
rispettare quindi in corso è una delle
pochissime cose che posso aprire quella
bocca perché c'era in casa da prima che
succedesse la pandemia perché ormai nei
confronti di ogni cosa che ho a casa mia
ho una specie di patteggiamento di paura
che timore perché mi sembra che
qualsiasi cosa sia contaminata
non è che si sciolga proprio torniamo
versate anche l'olio di semi controllori
90 ok di nuovo bilancio piatto un
aspetto che faccia da dare veramente
89,9 mi vanno bene acqua e olio
[Musica]
sembra un pochino la quetta che trovate
in alcuni tipi di scarichi ed è presente
quelli che potete alzarli vedere dentro
cucù che succede ecco sembra esattamente
quella questa che siete ora riprendete
le polveri setacciate aggiungetele un
cucchiaio alla volta le emulsioni di
acqua e zucchero e olio posso fare il
contrario non rientrano ma si se faccio
il contrario attacca è un po alla volta
non so se intendevano questo mi hanno
detto che il modo migliore per non avere
volumi a fare l'esatto opposto cioè mi
metto tutto ne frega niente
detto tutto ecco il modo migliore per
non avere volumi ecco grumi nell'animo
proprio non c'è tempo
setaccia e non fai chrome dai per favore
è in grado
mamma mia che blob raffreddore si chiama
torta al raffreddore muco e farina
mi ha guardato era piena zeppa di grumi
e soprattutto muco muco puro sto per
provare un metodo immergo questo che è
un colino dentro e cerco di schiacciare
tutto quanto in modo da filtrarlo è
veramente la scelta di un disperato
questa qui ma credo che sia l'unica che
al momento mi sento di poter prendere
l'unica il mio cervello mi suggerisce
magari avrei potuto frullarlo frullarlo
sono un genio togliamo i grumi
all'interno del sito suggeriscono di
imburrare una teglia mette la carta da
forno e compagnia simile io prenderò uno
stampo di un muffin perché non c'è una
teglia di 24 cm non mi va di un lehár lo
usera una cosa ancora migliore
attaccante a spruzzo ragazzi sto
parlando di una svolta in cucina un vero
alleato to spruzzi e spruzzi spruzzi e
poi ti stacca lui è per tutti quanti voi
chiamate questo genere immagini a voi
un'inquadratura molto in cui versa
no no no no
a questo punto forno preriscaldato a 180
gradi trattata da forno preriscaldato a
maurizio costanzo lo sbattiamo dentro
per 50 minuti io da momento che non
hanno turchi erano lui credo che darò 40
minuti e dopo farò la prova dello
stuzzicadenti vediamo che succede
ok ma quelle dei migliori e crei mamma
mia quanto è aumentato di finta di non
vederlo ciao buona scuola 40 minuti vai
countdown finale di s
l'odore buono ma questo rientra in
cucina che sembrava bottino non sembra
che la cottura sia andata così male a
far rivivere al cinico l'ora
perfettamente asciutto pronto quotate
non so se ve ne siete resi conto ma io
invece di metterla 50 minuti l'omessa 40
minuti perché avevo capito che essendo
più piccolo a beh quando si incomincia a
diventare così bravi capisco che si
possa mettere anche veramente in
difficoltà che ti guarda che viene solo
staccate a spruzzo fatto il suo lavoro
facciamo una mossa mossa il tremolio se
si si stacca no sto parlando
sta spopolando lungo
intanto che aspettiamo che si raffreddi
leggermente vi do una piccola dritta un
consiglio che sul sito è presente che
dice si possono realizzare moltissime
versioni tipo la torta all'acqua al
cioccolato al caffè oppure una torta
all'acqua limone e zenzero ci si può
sbizzarrire non abbiamo fatto quella
base ma ringraziamo giallo zafferano per
aver citato oltre questa ricetta un
sacco di altri spunti meravigliosi
l'unica domanda a questo punto è il
sapore che io vorrei provare anche se è
bollente come sempre vi ricordo di
iscrivervi a questo canale mettere un pò
licenziose è piaciuta questa ricetta
fatto lo è soprattutto di farmi sapere
se avete delle idee che cosa fare in
futuro perché poi vedete che le segue
sono una brava persona assaggiamo la
allora ne o tagliate già delle fette
somma è troppo calda ragazzi allora
buona
buona però inutile buona ma tocca
aggiungerci ripongo giusta di nutella
cioè un po un ciambellone ci mettevo
presa male
l'aiuto si questo alla fine oltre teatro
telepathe pure decidere le vene del fumo
ci vediamo martedì un ragazzino blog
ciao
non c'e niente di peggio di una cosa che
non è né buona né cattiva cioè che ti
lasciano così nella leggibilità
roma sta andando ancora scusate ciao